salut à tous ici envergure on devait
avoir un débat faute de combattants
on va dire nous allons repousser ce
débat de toute façon c'est un mode de
repousser les choses en ce moment les
matchs de basketball les résultats des
élections américaines et donc le débat
d'envergure en toute modestie qu'elle
prospère à la meilleure carrière ce sera
la prochaine fois en attendant épisode
spécial on a eu pas mal d'infos sur la
draft d'infos c'est un peu exagéré on va
dire des rumeurs mais ces rumeurs sont
intéressantes et elles viennent de
plusieurs sources et on a eu des rumeurs
qui sont revenus à nos propres oreilles
évidemment on ne dira pas d'où ça vient
on a entendu des petites choses pour
papoter tout ça il faut des papes
auteurs benoît manu alan romain salut
les gars c'est la bonne voie
professionnelle
je sais pas comment dire bonsoir en
alsacien donc je dire bonsoir
as tu sais toujours pas l'intégration
c'est plus ce que c'était
c'est un dialecte nasa si oui alors vous
il ya que des dialectes en province et y
accueille avec mais là il ya les plus
anciens qui n'ont pas encore un tel
soutien il ya encore pas mal de gens
c'est bon je suis vit pas au quotidien
mais notre intendant par encore parfois
bien et bien voilà une info déjà au bout
d'une minute trente de toutes pièces une
info géo polémique cet ordre d insight
je suis heureux sur avis assure ace et
compagnie et on a les infos qu'on mérite
épisode 39 les amis comme le pourcentage
aux lancers francs d'avenir mais c'est
parti
[Musique]
donc blague à part avant qu'on commence
on va rappeler à ceux qui écoutent les
bons réflexes à avoir
premier réflexe on réserve la nuit du 18
novembre
c'est la nuit de la draft pour ceux qui
n'avaient pas suivi
on sera en direct chez first team au
moins 1 espère peut être ailleurs
et je pense qu'on va beaucoup rire vu
les surprises que réserve la draft
encore cette année deuxième réflexe le
site envergure point ces eaux
on a plus de 50 scouting report
disponibles plus doublé fiche de tout
les joueurs de tous les prospects tous
les candidats c'est draft avec photo âge
mensurations et c'est donc il ya aussi
nos vidéos nos anciens podcasts les
vidéos de notre chaîne youtube et de nos
passages chez force team en ce moment
pour présenter les prospects donc ça
c'est sur notre site envergure point
ceoe dernier réflexe évidemment follow
sur twitter sur instagram c'est le même
@ envergure tiré du bas code messieurs
moi je peux me permettre gto mis quelque
chose avec ça il faut également préciser
que sur le site
nous allons créer une nouvelle rubrique
très bientôt pour les meubles dal avait
répertorié
on a eu beaucoup de mérite à nos vidéos
youtube demande de copains d'avant
pour garder nos sponsors exactement l
lagrange add qu'à demander à acheter
évidemment les meubles dahlan un certain
louis la brocante
c'est pas trop est-ce que c'est victor b
né ricol chef louis la brocante et en
une série télévisée mythique de bec
l'air trop francaise voila fr 3
messieurs
la première rumeur qui nous a été
importé c'est que nos amis les wolf qui
sont pour moi c'est pas tout de suite
nos amis les worlds qui sont en grande
hésitation avec leur force pis qu'ils
essaient raid le trait d mais
visiblement il demande beaucoup et le
pic a pas tant de valeur que ça se
répartit sur anthony edwards
quel chemin de purge en ce mois le ben
comment tu réagis à ça est ce que pour
toi c'est logique où est ce que pour toi
c'est un écran de fumée un snob screen
c'est peut-être c'est la solution
les ethnies il le met aux côtés de deux
des trois seules et 40 ans et ils en
font une option haute et à trois points
qui qui de mapa de switching mais une
option une option de tués lundi dans les
premières années une option tué md de
luxe et où les il laisse le temps de se
développer en tant que joueur je trouve
que c'est vraiment très important pour
donc c'est une solution qui c'est la
solution facile je voudrais que cette
année dans la draft il faut pas essayer
de se compliquer la tête donc ça ferait
beaucoup de sens pour moi que manu toi
qui a participé aux podcasts des fans
des rouge en france qui sont prêts une
dizaine
la critique est je suis toujours plus de
lui que d'adhérents au parti c'est une
association qui devient puissant dans un
chariot mais adore évidemment mais manu
qu est ce qu est ce que tu leur as dit
qu'est ce que toi tu en penses
qu'est-ce-qui comment ils voient eux
l'arrivée d'un potentiel d'un anthony
edwards chez eux les fans je suis du
même avis que ben je pense que c'est le
meilleur choix disponibles pour eux le
meilleur choix à faire ce que c'est le
choix pour moi aussi qui qui
correspondent mieux à la ghréline
entente avec la pub mais nos boulangers
leur seul donc eux sont pas contre il
aime bien aussi qu'il est il est encore
assez évasif sur le sur le souhait mais
ils sont quand même à ses chaussures sur
lui plus que plus car bull et bien
notamment ne fit quoi c'est ça
romain en ailier hyper athlétique aux
côtés de karl heinze kind côté de
d'angelo russell est ce que ça te ça te
plaise que tu aurais aimé un mec avec
plus d'expérience plus on sait que
anthony edwards s'est un peu les d'backs
parfois sur sur certains points
après après derrière le premier domino
ôta sais que mon équipe elle est en
reconstruction complète et permanente
depuis j'ai plaisir depuis sa création
je serai ce serait quand même est
conscient un petit peu le trait ils ont
ils ont quand même eu quelques années
quelques intéressantes mais moi ça me
paraît pas ça me paraît pas déconner
layard fait que dit angelo russell
blaisy team encore pas sûr que c'est
encore à son travail mais là encore
quelques belles années devant lui
il a montré à brooke sheen qui pouvait
porter l'équipe même s'il a beaucoup
beaucoup plus en du ballon car anthony
times etc c'est un petit peu un serpent
de mer dans cette franchise parce que cc
c'est un petit peu sur suis celui qui
doit qui devait ou qui devrait être le
franches de frein de chasse payeur aussi
là bas donc il y associer un poste 3 ça
commence à créer un peu une colonne
vertébrale de l'équipe voir le
supporting cast autour parce qu'on peut
en faire
après la question c'est toujours la même
c'est que qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il ya
d'autres de cohérent par rapport à sion
mais on parle de trade alors on peut
passer et asa clos qui a sorti un une
deux ou trois mais sur la lettre de
revendication le breton la vase ivi les
y allait si edward il est numéro 1 de
records dès qu'il le prenne ça me
dérange pas si les numéros 2 et que
c'est là mais le premier qui prennent
ils le prennent pas ce qu'il pense au
fid ça me dérange parce que je passe pas
outre un un potentiel comme la meinau
bol parce que j'ai danger leur seul dans
mon équipe et 41 et un peu dedans je
pense à un an tu commences études ont
démontré ce qu'il arrivera la fin de son
deuxième contrat et qui voudraient
gagner mais s'ils sont tous les deux
admettons sur le même tiers sur le même
c'est un aaa et un b même s'il préfère
la mélo ball mais qui sont dans le
vestiaire c'est à dire qui s'évalue à
peu près le même pot de même potentiel
même s'ils préfèrent légèrement
l'améliorer ce que retenait edward c'est
pas un peu plus de cohérence je sais pas
je ferais je sais pas c'est pour moi si
tu préfères un jour en 1 tu prends un
rêve après oui c'est pourrait faire sens
mais je parle je suis pas sûr qu'il faut
prendre en compte la possible
association etc rowsell on a dit on a vu
il a fait trois équipes pendant cinq ans
alors c'est ou c'était photo photo
compter sur laquelle ils étaient
quelques fois mais c'est pas un baigneur
établissent par un goy retentissent et
n'diaye donc je peux me permettre je
peux paraître une parenthèse le l'actuel
directeur de scouting assistant gm de
viande
gibbs et bien bouclée donc si si russell
et là c'est pas un hasard non plus c'est
vraiment là aussi il s'en prendre à
salindres
il ya peut-être quelque chose aussi la
dernière sert que y'a peut-être ya
peut-être après bon je ne suis pas je
suis pas dans le saint des saints les
bureaux je suis pas dans la corbeille à
papier de garçonne rosas mais c'est
peut-être aussi une envie de créer
quelque chose avec des joueurs d'avec
déjà deux joueurs comme articulations
c'est pas c'est pas déconner non plus je
ferme la parenthèse je te laisse pareil
ce qu'on m'accusait de monopoly il ya
des rumeurs les des rumeurs alan de de
trading pour toi ce que est ce que c'est
charlotte qui voudrait par exemple trade
up de 3 vers le premier choix on parle
de muybridge is plus le choix trois plus
un premier futur premier tour qui
seraient demandés par minnesota
est-ce que c'est crédible est-ce que ça
paraissait pas bah oui d'accord moi je
trouve mais je trouve que ça paraît
beaucoup ci a précisé cit a identifié un
profil comme cela dit qu'à plus utile
plusieurs profils à mme hétu valorise de
même de même manière dans le même noyau
même tirs je pense que c'est que tout ce
qui est petit feu se faire récupérer
encore 1 à 7 depuis l'année prochaine
est aussi charlotte envoie en ac ne sont
pas exceptionnelles je pense mais
l'année prochaine et que je suis je suis
très d'accord avec cette idée là moi je
ferais tuer dallas pour un braquage
je flippe 1 pour 3 je mens suivante
parce que on s'entend que est donné à
l'ouest de la meinau balle ils ont les
deux plus hauts plafonds de la drass
maison 2 du pub à plancher ou s'il va ça
va leur prendre une période d'adaptation
donc si moi je veut miser je me suis moi
je le disais je veux jouer au gameplay
dans le fond sur ce graphe tu sais ce
que je fais parce que je sais que
charlotte ce rapport incessamment
meilleur l'année prochaine surtout pas
avec est-ce que c'était une bonne idée
pour charlotte est ce que c'est crédible
de voir le front office de charlotte qui
est pas connu pour ses coups de génie
mais qui est pas non plus connu pour
pour faire n'importe quoi
ils sont misérables ils ont besoin d'eux
ils ont besoin de mettre des gens dans
les sièges ont besoin de mettre des gens
devant la télé donc la meinau balle
apparaît à la suite du départ de à la
suite du départ de pour charlotte donc
moi je trouve que ça s'appelle chances
de compter basket
nous avons perdu benoît coupure pardon
et manu est ce que je te souhaite bonne
s'ils montrent sa gêne a qui disent que
c'est pour chercher wiseman d'autres que
c'est pour chercher la mélo pas trop
pour anthony edwards visiblement mais
voilà la mélo ball on en parlait
continuez on nous confirme donc je parle
des rumeurs encore une fois qu'ils ne
sont revenus aux oreilles
on avait déjà entendu ça de la part de
je crois que c'est johnatan ou arman qui
disait la mélo ball a raté des
interviews soit on peux vous confirmer
que l'âme et lobo le père forme très mal
en interview
volontairement ou non telle est la
question
mais toujours est il que il passe un peu
pour un débile auprès de plusieurs
frontoffice dans les suites à la suite à
différentes interviews un mec un peu je
m'en foutiste un peu comme on
l'attendait comme c'est possible d'être
acteur pouvait l'attendre en tout cas
une personnage qui il donne à voir
depuis qu'il a
15 ans 16 ans c'est à dire grosse
confiance en soi mais ça peut avoir
aussi c'est le côté face on va dire de
sa personnalité
manu est ce que ça te surprend tant qu'à
regarder
j'imagine les interviews de bol avec
match m c'est assez cool parce que enfin
ce que par rapport à ce que tu dis est
ce qu'il le fait exprès parce que moi
j'ai rentré j'ai lu que hill in allait
faire des interviews qu'avec le top 4 on
m'a déjà des trois interviews programme
est donc déjà c'est faux c'est faux
parce que si c'est ça tu peux pas de
saborder comme ça c'est pas possible
sa stratégie est vraiment illisible si
c'est le cas comme dirait un nez aux
alsaciens et le stratégie qui est le
stratège c'est vrai et la tête de du
côté des bol des stratégies en bus c'est
ben que qu'en penses tu c'est volontaire
c'est pas volontaire cette surprend ses
portails volontaires moi je ne mets pas
sa frappe passa de la mélo balle mais on
s'entend qu'une entrevue
ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire aussi
je suis pour la première fois que
j'établis un parallèle entre ces deux
gars là mais que les thompson a été
drafté 11e en 2011 je crois parce que il
en partie parce qu'il est pas bien
performé aux entrevues jerry jerry west
qui drague qui drafté qui était
directeur du camping pour golden state
est absolument tombé en amour avec lui
pendant les bourgades mais il ya
plusieurs équipes qui trouvait qu'il y
avait là deux débiles en entrevue donc
moi je trouve que une lumière non je ne
dis pas que je dis pas que c'est pas une
lumière c'est pas le futur le plus c'est
qu'en egypte
je pense quand même à comprendre ce que
je veux dire c'est un joueur qui
s'exprime en juin bon joueur qui va
s'exprimera des grandes idées se jouera
que va prendre une vie qui lui est
propre sur le terrain m et romain
peut-être pu répondre à ça est ce qu'on
vise un top un pic du top 3 puisque
thompson il est choisi plus tard aussi
loin puisque ont misé un pic du top 3
sur un type qui nous paraît pas être un
philosophe comme on dit et ce qu'on mise
l'avenir de sa franchise là dessus vous
m'entendez ou non parce que j'avais
disparu
c'est une situation très particulière
que j'ai jamais été un grand fan du
grand fan du garçon et on va dire les
frasques des frasques lituanienne le
père et compagnie l'environnement ça m'a
jamais trop trop inspiré confiance
effectivement si les partis dans l'idée
de se dit on va faire écran de fumée on
vit dans des interviews
je pense qu'il faut quand même de sacrés
garantit aujourd'hui sa selle depuis
depuis quelques quelques saisons avoir
des garanties sur la draft c'est comme
trouver trace délais at war ducom par
quelque chose donc oui il ya des
stratégies le stratège comme tu l'as dit
tout à l'heure
moi je personnellement je ne saurais je
suis pas fan du joueur donc je peux
objectif j'aurais du mal à m'y risquer
et c'est sur un super mec a joué une
demi saison lituanie qui a joué en
australie dans un championnat qui n'est
pas forcément qui est super intéressant
offensivement il ya des très très bon
coach en australie mais qui est pas mon
cul le le plus dense physiquement qu'on
puisse trouver jeu j'aurais du mal à me
situer par rapport à par rapport à lui
alors elle cherchait très très où je
sais pas je il partira ou de toute façon
parce qu'à un moment ou un autre on peut
pas on ne peut pas avec l'aed qui a
autour
quand on est dirigeant du front si je
pense prendre le risque de passage de
passer à côté quand on peut la voir
et puis de voir le sérail her say say
say say 1
c'est une équation qui est difficile à
qui est difficile à ignorer à ne pas
rêver mais
je suis pas personnellement je m'en
sortir le dossier chinois
la parole est à la défense
alan malgré les interviews et ce qui ne
l'est pas est ce qu'on est ce qu'on
draft it aide pas oui c'est vrai
peut-être pas mais est ce qu'un joueur
qui rate complètement une interview est
ce que tu te dis comme ben finalement je
peux vivre avec
il s'exprime avec le ballon surtout si
c'est quand on voit la mélo jouer on
voit trop d'actions terrain et il est
assez intelligent quoi offensivement ils
devraient plus se dit instinctif quinté
il en sait pas fond c'est pas faux mais
tu vois quand même qui y voit il faut il
comprendre des situations offensives que
d'autres joueurs de son âge ne
comprennent pas que même des rainsy a
pensé ont du mal à avoir cependant après
est ce qui fait exprès de deux foires et
des interviews parce qu'ils passent que
dans sa tête à lui peut être drafté
direct l'initiateur et le leader de
l'équipe hellénique aussi thomas des
trois peut-être à new york ou même un
chicago il le sera je pense que c'est
une stratégie c'est pas une stratégie
mauvaise analogie mais l'état major
français en 39 fois c'est pas hyper
intelligent des rajouts s'interdit pas
ça très intelligent personnellement face
et c'est bête de penser comme ça après
après on ne sait quand on sait que
chaque draft
il ya des types qui refusent d'aller
workout avec telle équipe
jackson j'ai pas envie que la meilleur
rôle de venture jackson s'adorent un oui
mais deux je m'en rappelle que diane
drayton n'avait pas voulu workout avec
certaines équipes
marvin me voici enfin voilà complètement
il ya un trou noir qu'entre les work out
et sortent dire que tu es désinvolte
hautain et tu t'en fous en interview et
je ferai une petite différence bon
visiblement en tout cas selon les infos
qu'on a eu c'est
assez caractérisé le côté une interview
raté quoi surtout quand on entend que
beaucoup des prospects du haut du
tableau on parle de 2,9 dia on parle
même de james wiseman qui réussit pas si
mal ses interviews et estime comme
halliburton
on a des beaux parleurs aussi bien dans
le haut de la draft isaac au corps on
sait que c'est un mec droit
voilà c'est ça la met louis je pense que
même on l'a vu en interviewant cc3 mon
en réponse est oui c'est toi qui
l'interviewait ou icc déjà il brillait
pas par son éloquence
bon franchement c'est très simple non
c'est pas moi qui étais avec la mêlée
malheureusement c'est pas toi qui l'a
mis là je leur ai déjà ou halliburton
c'était des phrases c'était plusieurs
phrases lui dit c'est une phrase et par
le monde avec mes limites je les
trouvais ça pareil malgré lui poser la
question
il en fait si tu répondais mais il
rebondissait pas sur toutes les phrases
et tous qu'il a du mal à mettre des mots
sur des situations
en règle générale quand même quand il
parle de basket-ball introverti entre
vertiwind je voudrais je trouve très dur
les gars alors vas-y un développe
je vous trouve très bien il ya des gars
qui sait seulement c'est pas là
expertise de paris ce pas des parleurs
c'est pas des gars qui s'expriment
incroyablement cdi il y ait des gens qui
s'expriment pas verbalement dans la vie
que je crois que c'est pourtant le cas
s'il tanks des entrevues ça c'est dans
le domaine du possible mais je vous
dirais que c'est pas intelligent non
plus mais n'inquiète pas ni sur l'humain
c'est que je crois qu'il ya tous les
talents nécessaires pour parier sur
lui-même tant mieux si reprend confiance
en lui le ive oliver ingénierie sa
carrière nba il veut décider lui-même 8
11 6 et kbc tu aimerais tant mieux pour
lui tant mieux pour lui s'il réussit son
ben ali le mois d'après moi il citant me
tombera pas plus mais je pourrais me
tromper on peut tous se tromper
nouvelles news
qu'espère aux et on y sera
alors voilà quand j'avais écrit la mode
draft
on m'avait dit c'est un peu cliché les
spurs qui vont chercher un européen
fange
même si israël n'est pas en europe un
joueur d'euroligue
c'est un peu cliché croire les problèmes
avec la géopolitique non c'est juste
géographique leur objet aussi les
qualifs de l'europe géographique en
annonce que joe biden la loire on
parlera de joe biden juste après puisque
nous sommes désormais un peu caste
politique également petit hic les spurs
voudrait trade up pour aller chercher
denis abdilla source assez bien informé
quand même assez proche des san antonio
spurs alors ça vient pas du front office
mais ça vient de ska août qu'il invite
dans l'environnement d'espérance qu'en
pensez vous monsieur denis afdi ya donc
alors évidemment à l'heure où on
écrivait à la mode draft on ne pensait
pas ça on va pas se targuer d'avoir lu
dans mes les pensées des du front office
des spurs tant qu'ils ne l'auront pas
choisi mais c'est quand même intéressant
ça prouve deux choses que les spurs sont
prêts à 13 heures et ça ça se voyait un
petit peu et qu' ils ont des cibles
précises ils ont aussi interviewé onyeka
au congo où ils vont interviewer je sais
plus j'ai vu la nouvelle aujourd'hui
passer ce via un beat freighter un
journaliste qui suit de près les
l'espérance ben je suis alors manu est
ce que c'est une bonne situation ça
spurs
ah bah oui ça reste une maison quand
même réputé qui qui par le passé a
montré qu'ils savaient faire qui
choisissaient pas dire je vois au doigt
mouillé donc si l'on sait si l'on cible
un joueur
c'est qu'ils ont un une idée bien en
tête précisant il faut pas ça comme ça
donc après ce que c'est le bon fit je
sais pas très costaud pas grand monde à
l'aise quand ils ont pas grand monde à
l'aise si un jour il faut jouer l'euro
inquiète donc mais comme je m'en fous
moi c'est ce que je lui dis par rapport
à mme dia est ce que disait sherbrooke à
des mauls
c'est pour moi vias et c'est un honneur
et c'est pas un ailier donc déjà j'ai un
petit problème avec ça est-ce que alors
allah n'est pas d'accord mais il passait
un initiateur un peu un demi initiateurs
et peut pas défendre mon orgueil c'est
impossible
je pense par m oui la sinne à petit ça
c'est sûr le choses encore mais pour moi
offensivement ces îles haida tout du
sacre atteignant et ses principales
forces et c'est là dessus donc
[Musique]
donc on doit venir jeudi en israël il
c'est là dessus qu'il est meilleur quand
il jouer à l'intérieur ils étaient
beaucoup moins bon beaucoup plus
beaucoup moins inclus dans le jeu il
arrivait plus plus trop à se mettre
dedans et à se montrer alors que quand
il a la balle en moi incroyable bonheur
quoi quand ils voient ils voient tout
pour tout ce qu'il faut voir donc pour
moi il sera meilleur à ce poste là que
en 3 4 qu'est ce qui l'attend vendredi
l'année en tête là dessus alors alan toi
qui as fait le podcast avec les fans des
spurs s'agit pas de bêtises ils ont pas
de alors à part de roseanne qui est un
des joueurs qui drive le plus au cercle
mais qui a toujours ce problème de
wrench de distance de tir
ils n'ont pas de d'initiateur comme tu
dis de joueurs capables de créer du jeu
élite les spurs
non non mais après il s'en sort grâce à
voilà en collectif au jeu de passes et
clichés quand on parle des spurs mais
c'est vrai en même temps ils sont pas en
prison
ils ont drafté par le fonds est investi
sur des quads ces derniers temps avec
surtout murray et wild a même si white
on sait pas ce qu'on pourra le garder
mais au niveau financier mais au moins
je trouve pas ça va être franchement
pour aller chercher un visa parce 3,4
polyvalent comme je les dis avec martin
qui peut passer dribbler shooter dans la
philosophie de jeu des spurs trouve ça
bien et après qu'au caractère gros
bosseur et pour le modeler pendant
carpio d'après moi je pense pas que ça
sera un on initie un mois un mineur ou
un ministère où il a fait que l'équipe
devienne d'israël mais en euroligue il
pouvait pas le faire c'est passé wilber
kiné d'orsay qui était qui étaient les
meneurs de l'équipe alors c'est normal
que ce ne sont pas parce que c'était
cuit établi des joueurs pros et tout ça
mais aussi promis c'est parce que le
niveau de claix making pour pas tout de
suite en ont pas tout de suite et en
tant que pollinisateurs principalement
deuxième froideur ouais ça va je pense
que oui bon en tout cas c'est pas bête b
romain l'espère aux cantines trade pour
aller chercher un joueur c'est
généralement qu'il ya quelque chose qui
se passe au niveau de l'interview on se
rappelle même il ya longtemps
enfin la cantine draft parker alors jean
augustine pile ou face des cantines
draft par coeur comme même quand hydrate
kawai
quand ils veulent un joueur il identifie
assez bien psychologiquement les joueurs
qui pourraient aller dans leur système
oms à khaldiya c'est une grosse
personnalité mais c'est pas si étonnant
par rapport à voile à son environnement
familial qui est fan tous les signaux
les hinton giebel ce qu'on me dise sont
positifs avec ce joueur
voilà on dit souvent vous m'entendez il
ya pas de souci je ne suis pas habitué à
cette nouvelle nouvelles technologies
que tu nous impose on sait c'est un peu
une forcé des portes ouvertes mais le
modèle de construction de l'équipe
d'évaluation des joueurs et de don de
scouting à des spurs a un petit peu
changé le changer la donne en nba quand
quand ils ont commencé à assumer leur
propre fonctionnement et beaucoup de
beaucoup de franchise sont sont d'une
part inspiré notre part on construit des
modèles similaires parce qu'aujourd'hui
des gens des spurs a un petit peu
partout donc oui effectivement on peut
clairement dire que veut qu'ils ne sont
pas le plus gros marché dessus du
continent nord-américain haut niveau au
niveau du basket a aidé à construire des
équipes par cette expertise
aujourd'hui seulement l'idée de vouloir
trailer pour aller chercher quelqu'un
comme f10 à ces cas inévitablement
quelque chose en terme de fuites d'une
part mais également en termes de ventes
et remet d'une telle est en cas de deux
prises informations sur le sur le joueur
après ce que la rumeur se confirme on ça
c'est encore autre chose mais je ferai
plus confiance aux spurs dans dance est
dans cette démarche
quelle autre équipe peut-être parfois
mon bien aspirés par le passé sachant
que de mémoire des bosses à san antonio
il a quand même pas eu des masses alors
oui il ya toujours eu des contacts sont
généralement quand même souvent choisi
après la 20e place ces dernières années
mais par le succès qu'ils ont pu créer
sportivement mais même en choisissant
bas ils ont souvent réussir à faire des
styles et aller chercher des joueurs
moins d'arabes de ginobili
même si on a déjà parlé qu'elle est elle
un petit peu le fruit du hasard malgré
tout c'est une belle perf parker en dise
qu'on en veut on construit on veut du
joueur et la carrière qu'il a eue au le
fhaine poloff aime tout ça s'est passé
pas la question attendons pour quelqu'un
qui est de racheter aussi bas c'est
pareil c'est un style énorme par rapport
aux positions été drafté quand on voit
la carrière qu'il a fait le fait d'avoir
été aux stars champions league qui
défile avec ses terres excitant voilà il
ya un savoir faire
je pense que plus que l'autre ont la
capacité
de dévaluer le gamin après derrière est
ce que ça fonctionne ou pas céder dans
la question entre potentiel et
potentiels à réaliser on a encore sur un
autre sur la glorieuse incertitude du
terrain mais pas inquiets qu'ils soient
dans cette démarche là où contrat c'est
même plutôt rassurant pour le lien le
seul bémol que j'ai par rapport à lui
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure en
début dans des buts propose c'est la cas
plastique avoir défendu sur des joueurs
plus petits ou plus athlétique
parce que surtout ce qui est hui basket
création et ainsi de suite sur les
aspects offensifs
je les ai vus jouer quand même plusieurs
fois l'année dernière j'ai le souvenir
d'un match où il est passé totalement au
travers contre liptako sur nos briques
mais mais globalement c'est plutôt
solide
après derrière voilà cesser les aspects
défensifs c'est un petit peu ce qui
avait été la limite de deux rivaux de
l'époque qui avait qu'à pas pourquoi
tous les outils sauf peut-être l'aspect
défensif et l'impact de ce côté là donc
voilà avoir à voir la notation je mène
ce cette possibilité d'un trade up des
spurs pour aller chercher de njawe dia
alors précision on dit à mme dia pour
tous ceux qui écoutent et qui leur
diront ensuite puisque le papa vient de
serbie si j'ai bien je si j'ai bien tout
suivi les différents débats et
pointereau aussi ils n'ont pas de
croatie pour ne froisser personne
ben je reviens à ma question afd il ya
spurs spurs qui vont chercher un joueur
assez haut qui ont identifié un joueur
qui ça veut dire que vraiment pendant
les interviews pendant les work out ils
se disent ce gala peut faire passer
notre équipe à un niveau supérieur
ouais ben moi je déteste pas l'idée
parce que c'est une équipe qui vaut une
équipe qui comprend beaucoup qui est
qu'une bonne attitude à comprendre à
quoi les joueurs sont bons parce que les
joueurs sont capables de faire et on
peut lui demander d'en faire trop il
faut pas lui demander de faire des
choses qui sont qui sera pas capable de
faire comme par exemple dire pour
l'instant moi sa capacité à son premier
pas ses capacités un bateau de francs
soit le contraire pour moi sa robe de
sanoma un aspect très suspect les
comparaisons paraît sûre je ne perds le
compas toujours à l'ucad en chine
une bible pour moi c'est là c'est la
différence numéros entre les deux villes
et pour l'instant incapable de battre
son défenseur et mais si ceux ci tombent
aux spurs
on parle d'une équipe qui est capable de
prendre
qu'est ce qu'il est capable d'apporter
une équipe qui est pas non plus au mal
qui est pas besoin d'un sauveur donc oui
moi je dis il me tendit je pense que tu
l'avais dit avoir tué deux places avec
les hawks où on envoie un derrick white
box avec un autre prospects disons je
sais pas qu'ils ont drafté l'année
dernière un long et wacker plus la 11e
choix pour dénier à moi je trouve que ça
mais c'est quelque chose qui fait sens
pour des deux côtés certains parlaient
même de démarrer rosen
après faut que les salaires s'éclipser
mais c'est ça c'est ça fait du sens sur
papier messieurs avant de passer à la
suite on parlera des boston qui selon
plusieurs sources de cette fois
américaine pas du côté de chez nous
voudraient trade up avec leurs trois
piques au premier tour
14 26 30 croit certaines équipes player
fable donc les hommes qui étaient en
playoffs cette année cherchera à monter
dans le top 10 on ose demander qui et
puis certaines vous certains voudraient
vendre ou acheter du second tour ça
c'est un faux de 2 à clos
qu'il a sorti aujourd'hui sur i espionne
pour avoir papoté lui aussi avec 10
différents différents membres de front
office mais avant un point sur
l'élection américaine avec notre envoyé
spécial dans le comté de gwyneth romain
leroy
romain c'est ce comté de la fac de
savannah stade qui pourrait faire
basculer élections américaines si bien
compris
bah ouais alors c'était un petit peu un
petit peu tout à l'heure je bon jeu
j'essaie de de m'intéresser à ce qui se
passe dans le monde mais donc non j'ai
voulu faire une grande phrase et c'est
pas marché alors j'ai vu ça tout à
l'heure totalement par hasard est en
fait le journaliste je ne sais plus quel
network américain expliquait que tel
conte est elle compte et elle comptait
en géorgie et donc voilà le seul celui
et la ville de savannah été clairement
mentionné donc seul ce contest de de
bruyne est d'ailleurs pour être précis
puisque c'était h à la fin pour rempli
de vos cours d'anglais
donc c'était un c'était visiblement en
termes de nombre de populaire je passe
la population que tout ça c'était
peut-être ce comté qui pouvait faire
basculer la géorgie pour bayonne
voilà et cqfd nous ça fait deux ans et
curieux de savannah state comme un d'une
saclay finalement on savait on savait
déjà et ça c'est une équipe qui n'a pas
peur d'être audacieuse donc ça ne nous
étonne pas on a toujours dit on renvoie
nos podcasts de l'année dernière pour
ceux qui n'ont pas du tout compris ce
qu'on vient de dire ça va state était la
fac qui prenaient le plus de tirs à
trois points de n'diaye mais de très
très loin des 40 tirs par match a dit
giannoli tirée de très très loin et très
très loin je crois que c'était 52 tirs
par match
je jouais quand on voyage réserve 1 un
record à 52 53 et en moyenne il était à
40 quoi donc un parmi leurs jus
permanente
c'est magnifique magnifique c'était le
rêve les rêves les plus fous de mike
d'antoni
en fait m revenons au basketball enfin
non et non basket ball mais je veux dire
revenons à cette draft 2020 boston qui
voudraient trade up pour aller chercher
quel joueur peut être un élément de
réponse
un interprétation assez basique mais
alan il me semble que tu as vu un truc
sur leurs réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
aux celtics ouais qu'ils ont pas ils ont
partagé sur un store un petit clip de
hergé entonne alors je suis pas un petit
petite présentation doit faire deux
trois actions il met ses stats et il
fait des autographes avec des héros jake
les yeux qui regardent et c'est la
première fois qu'ils font ça pour un
joueur je crois que c'est la première je
suis en direct je te laisse en direct
mais et pour moi c'est la fois que je
pense que ça va un peu choquer donc
c'est pour ça que j'en ai parlé mais
c'était une des premières fois bons airs
jameson aux celtics
quelle est l'opinion de manu on sait pas
un joueur qu'on elle n'est pas le joueur
qu'on a le plus joué vers johnston et ça
c'est que c'est un projet mais qui a du
potentiel
ouais c'est ce serait quoi il faut que
je trouve un peu là l'image des spurs si
ils ont un joueur ciblé c'est qu'ils ont
ils ont quelque chose de bien clair en
tête et qu'ils savent vraiment de quoi
ue du coup il en ressort que c'est
étonnant mais chut je suis pas étonné
qu'il ya eu un coup de coeur quoi c'est
qui est vrai vainqueur
moi j'ai entendu quelque chose alors
vas-y ben entendu vu que il avait les
yeux diriger vers onyeka ce qui pour moi
fait beaucoup ils ont chois 14e mais ils
ont aussi le 26 et le 30
ils ont des choix dans les futaies draft
aussi ils peuvent 14 août
douze ils ont les armes pour trouver
d'offres le soir la grève donc ça
m'étonnerait beaucoup qui va le faire
tout ce bruit là pour harrington
j'ai entendu que onyeka comme vous
c'était le gros corps dont ils avaient
besoin
devant le panier pour finalement
compétitionner avec les équipes peu plus
de mes oignons et quand on en parle
jusqu'au pic 3 quelle équipe serait
vendeuse dans lé le top 6 7 par rapport
à onyeka aucun goût et qu'est-ce que
boston devrait envoyer en échange
alan je peux si tu as des idées mais où
manioc dans les points vas-y pas si
longtemps on peut pas le garder les
trois premiers tours chapeau c'est bien
sauf s'ils iront dans un pur style mais
je veux dire 14 +26 moi je donne pas mon
choix 6 sapa non mais oui c'est vrai
mais on peut venir avec si une équipe
devait envoyer un roméo l'emploi de
l'année passée et vous appelle et peu
impressionné qu'il peut mais robert
williams club au salut voilà qui n'est
pas si horrible que ça et ça elle peut
devenir après moi aussi je veux savourer
compliqué de monter très haut
déjà il va falloir se séparer de
certains contrats je pense que peut-être
le pitre ans qui va être utilisé pour
fourguer canter s'il prend ça sidati son
option et poisseux suspension le rire
sadique du new yorkais il faut il faut
aussi voir ce qui se passe avec vincent
poirier en termes de contrats ce qui
racontera garantie pour l'année
prochaine et n'a pas joué du tout à
cette année donc monté si haut que ça ça
me paraît ça me parait pts était étrange
après si tu peux monter avec atlanta je
pense que c'est possible si tu peux
monter avec après atlanta serait bien
été trois peut-être est-ce que tu es des
trois ans je pense qu'ils sont un
processus de longue longue longue durée
donc peut-être que s'ils veulent les
leurs à cette plusieurs pics de draft
ils peuvent se dire noir et 26 dans
cette draft là sachant qu'un année
prochaine on sera mauvais on va sûrement
essayer d'avoir le premier pic de
l'année prochaine leurs pions
au drame de jeunes plutôt qu'un ans est
si long plus profil qu'ils annoncent est
roi mais l'argent tonnes ça me surprend
pas en fait ça me surprend pas que angie
sea ng apprécier le profil personnel
hockey l'intéressant c'est vrai qu'ils
n'ont pas peur de prendre des shooteurs
qui savent pas shooter des joueurs cette
faculté france
ils se trompent des phocéens à l'omnium
d'italie s'est trompé les et il s'est
trompé diane et ses angles il s'est
trompé
donc ça arrive tout le monde se trompe
tout le monde se trompe donc boston
pourrait faire partie de ces équipes qui
étaient en playoffs qui cherche à monter
dans le top 10 est-ce que vous en voyez
d'autres je pose la question à la volée
répondre à qui veut ok si mais peut-être
de manière indirecte
ok si qui voudraient monter dans le top
intéressant se séparent avant ses
parents de certains à 7 en fait c'est
pas ils vont monter le sexy se sépare de
des niches fraudeurs peuvent récupérer
un pic aux alentours s'est excusé c'est
clermont paul genre de baraf tout du
monde pour chercher des joueurs ce qui
n'a pas forcément une grosse quantité de
joueurs s'y alimenter internet de m tu
vas te délester en fait de ce que tu as
déjà pour anticiper autre chose derrière
oui oui c'est ça c'est liana bureau a
clôt parlaient de monter pour aller
chercher un choix qui serait en fait un
profil manquant pas forcément pour aller
chercher un choix dans le top 10 qui
serait voilà une sorte de das est pour
un futur trade quoi c'est à dire un truc
est diffusé à 20h05
ce qui veut dire que là si on une équipe
qui commencerait à traîner vers le haut
en fonction de sa situation actuelle
ça peut vouloir dire aussi que certains
vont tab et des process de
reconstruction sur deux trois ans par le
fait justement que se délester de ok si
elle est effectivement que si en plein
dedans subtilement ok si effectivement
dernière chose à une question peut-être
pour ben à claude en le voyant son son
article parle de franchise vendeuse de
choix du second tour
d'autres plutôt acheteuse on parle de
détroit notamment treiber a dit
explicitement qu'il n'hésiterait pas à
sortir du cash pour aller prendre un
choix au second tour
est ce que pour toi ça c'est une bonne
idée d'aller acheter des choses mon tour
en souvient que notamment jordan belle
avait un choix qui étaient achetés par
les warriors à l'époque cette année plus
que notre jeu parce que cette année il
ya beaucoup de joie je voudrais que
entre 10 et 40 on dit il ya une bonne
différence de talent on a beaucoup de
joueurs qui n'ont pas eux qui ont
beaucoup de talent qui fait à peu près
nulle part pour aucune équipe qui sont
qui ont vraiment un profil bizarre et
atypique pour la nba donc je pense que
entre 30 et 40 qu'il ya un gros
potentiel à trouver des styles la draft
on parle de on parle de desmond bing qui
part qui passe entre 25 et 35
moi j'ai personnellement je crois pas
qu'il veut passer le pic de mai je
pourrais me tromper
on parle d'un emmanuel quickly que buemi
aurait workout bien mais qui ont leur
pic numéro 20 donc si mes amis vont
miser sur les manuels quitely au numéro
un on voit s'acheter un pic de deuxième
tour je trouve ça
clairement intéressant donc oui moi je
pense que c'est une année où la médiane
des joies absolument
donc ça pourrait valoir le coup
d'acheter des pics du second tour voilà
où on en est exclu pour terminer il ya
une autre rumeur qu'on n'a pas évoqué et
que vous vouliez évoqué sur laquelle
vous vouliez rebondir
peut-être pas une rumeur mais une
nouvelle que je veux oui je t'écoute
on a eu les résultats des duels de 3 oui
oui c'est ton petit à petit et on a on a
une constance vraiment un curieux cecos
pro d2 l'ailier de louisville absolument
détruite le moyen sur os propre os x
europe
le test pour la partie nord 82 pour sa
hausse paddock endurance pour ceux qui
sont pros cole qui sont pas familiers
avec l'adulte c'est le sport adapté cinq
minutes de trois colloques à vitesse 78%
et met par exemple aux tirs en mouvement
il est absolument hors il est absolument
pas d'un top 10
j'avais compris la ville a acheté sur
plan basket mais ça sent quand sans
doute de là bas et moi je suis
personnellement je trouve que c'est une
question de consistance molle qui est
capable d'être série dans le plus
désolant mais ça ça je le comprends mais
si tu veux le truc c'est je pense que
c'est c'est vraiment pour aller chercher
un petit peu dans les ressources
mentales et un petit peu sont ration des
joueurs parce que j'ai à aucun moment
aujourd'hui sur un match de basket
tu joues cinq minutes d'affilée plein
pièce c'est impossible ça n'existe pas
donc ça va moi je suis un chien chez un
petit peu un inconvénient
un acharné de la contextualisations en
termes de formes de travail
ceci dit ceci dit romain il vaut mieux
shooté à 82% sur un exercice comme celui
là qu'à 20% ou alors aux demeures oui
j'avais voilà et encore une fois il vaut
mieux shooté à 82 % soit le v6 comme ça
que assis sur une chaise en envoyant des
fléchettes à trois points sont bougés et
non mais ça tout à fait mais c'est le
l'objectif de genre d'exercice il n'est
clairement pas basket filière là je
comprend l'évaluation mais bon j'ai
parfois eu des vidéos à voir deux des
vidéos pardon de wockhardt avec des
trucs qui était pour moi un petit peu
hallucinante
d'accord j'ai participé au basketball
without borders une année anton coach
mon style il ya un peu plus de dix ans
la cua cette année mais ça s'était fait
à paris j'ai vu des trucs très curieux
et dans l'évaluation et dans la
construction des équipes que les clés
que les scouts et les coaches qui
étaient là faisait pour la porte pour
les oppositions mais voilà c'est les
objectifs sont pas forcément technique
dans ces trucs là c'est aussi choisir ce
que bon je savais sa victoire depuis
lundi dans l'est dans le top 5 dans
l'es3 de l'urd à trois points bien passé
je ne vais pas mal je trouve
daschle le boy alex rider à ce qu'un
accord avec une consistance absolument
admirable la journée chose curieuse les
3 pour 1 au mouvement
c'est qu'à la boisson de quelques relais
le plus dans ces fonds étaient pas mal
aussi
il me sa cote monte effectivement arrive
à pic pour jordan noura ça n'étonne que
vous mon cher benoît
je vous rappeler que je l'avais j'ai vu
autour de 30e
dominique bon ben moi aussi j'avais 33
ou 38 quelque chose genre mais je dis il
manque quand même une certaine
consistance qui pourra lui donner un
rôle vraiment solide sur les bases on va
dire et ce dont tu parles je vais finir
là-dessus ça me rappelle quand on
rappelle que les équipes nba ont le
droit de workout que dix joueurs cette
saison que les drills ce dont tu parles
c'est la vidéo du pro d2 chaque joueur
donc et codifié avec des exercices à
faire etc
mais les équipes n'ont le droit qu'à des
work out et donc ses mensurations ses
dribbles de shooting même si ils sont
évidemment contestable comme l'a
expliqué romain ça risque de compter un
petit peu plus peut-être que les autres
années dans l'évaluation des prospects
du fait il ya du manque d'exposition
entre guillemets réel des des joueurs
c'est à dire que les franchises
elles vont faire leur dise interview
plus work out
et puis elles vont se rendre compte
qu'un 11e a eu des mensurations
excellente a fait des drills super et
vont passer de trois coups de fil
puisque ça parle aussi entre ce cap de
différentes équipes ou entre membres de
médias qui ont pu voir jouer tel ou tel
joueur est peut-être qu'elles ont drafté
un des joueurs qu'elles n'ont pas vu
workers sur la base de ces évaluations
justement de mensurations de et de et
d'exercices sur les capacités techniques
le shoot etc c'était la conclusion
essieux on se retrouve pour le débat
c'était l'épisode 39 je vous remercie
d'avoir participé à ce podcast qui
étaient enregistrés avec une nouvelle
méthode on attend vos retours sur le son
notamment
n'oubliez pas d'aller vous abonner sur
votre podcast sur votre plateforme
d'écouté favorite
si vous nous écoutez on est cerné par
toute façon
vous écoutez sur spotify sur deezer sur
google podcast sur apple podcast peu
importe vous pouvez vous abonner à la
chaîne envergure désormais c'est plus
les podcasts rose transatlantique c'est
envergure on vous abonner et puis si
vous aimez bien vous mettez 5 étoiles et
si vous aimez pas vous mettez rien si
vous avez beaucoup beaucoup ou peu
nourri de l'ordre voilà vous pouvez nous
envoyer de l'argent
sponsorisé doux ou plus ou plutôt
acheter un tee shirt
voilà bien sûr acheter un tee shirt et
voilà merci à vous d'avoir écouté et
merci à vous d'avoir participé manu alan
romain ben a plus les gars a plus le feu